today on the matt walsh show the left
celebrates when white characters and
films and tv shows are turned black but
reacts with outrage in the reverse
this is yet another example of the
blatant racial double standards that
govern our society and personally i've
had enough of them we'll talk about it
also cnn shocks the world by sort of
acknowledging that the byu racism story
was a hoax though the race-baiters over
on espn are sticking with their story
facts be damned dr oz comes out in favor
of the federal government redefining
marriage and brian stelter loses his job
at cnn only to immediately end up on the
staff at harvard what does this tell us
about the institutions that run our
country quite a lot actually we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
matt welsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
inflation is making a lot of us spend
more than we used to on gas groceries
really just about everything that that
can be detrimental to your household
budget but it doesn't have to be that
way just give our friends at american
financing a call for a free mortgage
review i can't stress this enough your
home is an investment tool and it
continues to appreciate at record levels
you can access cash from that investment
at competitive rates as long as you take
action soon the fed is meeting this
month and um is uh they're expected to
raise rates again so don't miss your
opportunity and don't miss your chance
to save some money and do what you can
to help your own finances you're not
getting a lot of help from the
administration obviously you can get a
great deal in as little as 10 days by
calling american financing get a free
mortgage review from a salary-based
mortgage consultant there's no pressure
no obligation no upfront or hidden fees
just a simple conversation around custom
loans that can fit your budget better
call
forty
866
eleven that's eight six six five six
nine forty seven eleven or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls 182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org
back in august it was announced that the
actor james franco had been cast to play
fidel castro in an upcoming film as
axios reported at the time the casting
decision sparked anger many on the left
accused franco of participating in
whitewashing the washington post ran an
article claiming that the incident
highlights the alleged ongoing problem
of latino exclusion in hollywood fellow
actor john leguizamo blasted the casting
as appropriation called for a boycott
many others agree that franco should not
be allowed to appropriate a brutal
dictator from latinos he may be a mass
murdering psychopath but he's there mass
murdering psychopath damn it it didn't
matter that franco actually looks a lot
like fidel castro it also didn't matter
that franco and castro are not that far
apart ethnically castro's father was
from spain while franco's grandfather is
from portugal it also of course didn't
matter that the job of an actor
is to act that is to pretend to be
something that you are not none of that
matters in such cases all that matters
is that franco is white
and white people must stay in their
acting lane now by the way john
leguizamo was born in colombia
but his first prominent role in
hollywood was portraying the nintendo
character luigi who is an italian
plumber according to the nintendo canon
that doesn't matter either though as
we'll cover in a moment
now over the years there have been many
outrages and controversies stemming from
instances of alleged whitewashing the
anger is no less palpable when the role
in question is a fictional character in
2017 a british actor was forced to drop
out of a hellboy film because the
character he was supposed to play was
japanese in the original comic a few
years before that emma stone's casting
as an asian woman in a romantic comedy
provoked so much wrath from the left
that the director of the film had to
issue a written apology for the film he
directed and stone herself has since
apologized for her participation in the
project that same year rooney mara had
to grovel and beg for forgiveness
after starring as tiger lily in a peter
pan adaptation the left declared that
the fictional character is supposed to
be native american rooney mara is not
and she agreed and now she says that
she's haunted by guilt because of uh
portraying that character in the film
the outrage extends into the cartoon
realm as well where last year
hank azaria famously apologized and
announced that he was stepping away from
his role as a poo in the simpsons on the
basis that he shouldn't be voicing a
character of indian descent in fact the
show's producers
have since said that no white voice
actors will be used for any characters
from other ethnic backgrounds from now
on
the determination to root out all cases
of whitewashing quote unquote or
suspected whitewashing or potential
whitewashing is so absolute that the
live-action remake of aladdin in 2019
came under fire because the brown
actress who played jasmine was not brown
enough and she wasn't white but she
appeared to be kind of white adjacent
and that was very disturbing
a screen rant article at the time said
that aladdin's whitewashing had damaged
its box office potential
the writer apparently convinced that the
average moviegoer shares her
race-obsessed neurosis
now it may then come as a surprise
to the most naive among us anyway
that the very same media which complains
bitterly about whites in traditionally
non-white roles and the very same
leftists who treat the the whitening of
non-white characters as literal genocide
and all the people who've taken this
issue so seriously as to cause many
white hollywood actors to drop out of
films and fall to their knees and
apology
would all this week be so excited about
the release of the first trailer for
disney's upcoming little mermaid live
action copy and paste job now everything
is mostly the same in the remake as
always it's like shot for shot exactly
except
that the little mermaid herself a pale
redhead in the cartoon version has been
recast as a black woman though still
with red hair somehow this is part of a
growing trend as the anger about
whitewashing increases
so in equal proportion does the demand
for what we must in the reverse call
blackwashing a viral post on twitter
declares rapturously a black cinderella
a black bell on broadway a black
cinderella on broadway and now a black
ariel the black girls are truly winning
much the left's approval the black girls
are winning quote-unquote in historical
retellings too last year a black woman
was cast as ann bolin the 16th century
queen of england in an upcoming
mini-series
netflix currently features a show
starring a black woman as a viking
warrior
many other examples come to mind too
many to count they even fired jake from
state farm and replaced him with a black
version
and then there are the examples yet to
be for instance there's still a major
push to find somebody other than a white
man to fill james bond's shoes in the
next installment
now in all of these cases
two things are guaranteed
or actually more than two a few things
when when a black actor plays a
traditionally white role portraying
either a fictional character or a
historical figure
the media the left and hollywood itself
will celebrate the move as pioneering
and courageous and important along with
all the other requisite superlatives
the other guarantee is that any
criticism of the casting decision even
and especially criticism that simply
adopts the same logic as the left
applies to so-called whitewashing
will be slammed as racist
the daily beast today has an article
documenting what it calls the racist
backlash to the black little mermaid uh
declaring this backlash to be out of
control the racism is out of control
they say
then you click on the article
and in the article they provide a few
tweets from random accounts complaining
that the underwater scenes don't look
realistic
so the daily beast article about racist
backlash contains no racist backlash or
even backlash that vaguely mentions race
they simply determine that the criticism
of the film's bad cgi is really racially
motivated it's a dog whistle as they
like to say
that's the third guarantee that when a
film casts a black actor in a white role
any criticism of the film
any criticism even criticism makes no
mention of race is racist which is why
you can't criticize the new lord of the
rings series or the game of thrones
prequel without revealing yourself to be
a member of the kkk
in such situations
the left also likes to employ its
favorite sleight of hand trick that we
talk about all the time on this show
this is something that they will surely
use in response to this very monologue
you're listening to right now when media
matter media matters clips it and post
it to twitter with a caption like daily
wire host launches into racist tirade
about black little mermaid guaranteed
they're going to do that and when they
do the left is going to go to respond to
it by scoffing and saying why do you
care so much it's just a movie about a
mermaid it's just a mini-series about
the queen of england it's just a show
about a viking it's just entertainment
why are you even talking about this
aren't there more important issues
but of course
they themselves have made exceedingly
clear that racial accuracy in
entertainment whether fictional or
historical is extremely important to
them they've been saying this for years
that's why they go into spasms of rage
whenever a character is judged not black
or brown enough
it's why they would literally riot and
start killing people if somebody
rebooted tyler perry's medea series
except with
bob odenkirk dressed in drag for the
title role
a similar reaction would be expected if
the live-action remake of the princess
and the frog featured like kristen
stewart as tatiana and of course a
biopic about say frederick douglass with
tom hanks as the lead would result in
entire cities burning down in flames
all of these things would be called
as less egregious examples have been
called black erasure
so does that not mean by their own
categorization
that the reverse is white erasure
and if they can complain about black
erasure then why can't we complain about
white eurasia any kind of erasure on
racial grounds sounds bad to me
well no they say it's different in the
reverse
it's just different
it always is right
and that's why all of this matters now
on its own
in a vacuum
the race of an actor portraying a
fictional character or even a historical
character doesn't matter makes no
difference right that's exactly the
point that many of us have insisted on
for years when the left started making
this an issue for years we said it's not
an issue who cares and there was a time
when when that was the case it wasn't an
issue nobody really cared about it
morgan freeman's character in shawshank
redemption is actually supposed to be an
irish guy with red hair that's why the
character is named red
but nobody complained because freeman
was brilliant in the role he
single-handedly made that film the
classic that it is and also back in the
early 90s people weren't obsessing as
much about the racial dynamics in
hollywood films there was nothing
pointed or political about giving the
role to freeman
contrary to now
when the diversification quote unquote
of a story is always very clearly
pointed and political
back then he was just the best man for
the job everyone loves his character now
and that's all that needs to be said
many of us have clung to that attitude
today which again in a vacuum makes
sense
but we're not in a vacuum
unfortunately we live now in a culture
governed by blatant racial double double
standards
the the rightness or wrongness of an act
the seriousness or unseriousness of an
issue
the legitimacy or illegitimacy of a
complaint
even the mutability or immutability of a
cartoon character's race are all judged
on racial grounds
based on skin color we are told what our
opinions are allowed to be
and what sorts of things we are allowed
to care about
and if you're white
then there's going to be a whole list of
things that every other group of people
can care about
but which you would be insane stupid
petty and racist to care about yourself
entire lists of priorities which due to
your skin pigmentation are off limits
for you
you are not allowed to care about it
they say we're supposed to just accept a
rule which says you know having a white
actor play black panther is horribly
racist but it's also horribly racist to
complain about a black actor playing the
little mermaid
but that rule is indefensible and
hypocritical in the extreme
and we all know it and yet we're
supposed to just acquiesce to it
that's what all this is about in the end
it's not about the movies i don't even
watch any of these movies on their own i
don't care about them
i do care about the racial double
standard which we are being conditioned
to accept
because another word for racial double
standard is
racism
this is all racist
and that's why it matters
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
with the ever-increasing numbers of
makes and models it's impossible for a
traditional chain storefront to stock
all the parts you need why wait while
the man at the counter orders parts for
your car from the brand that his
warehouse happens to carry you don't
need to do that you have a computer in
your pocket just go to rockauto.com
rockgutter.com has been in the auto
parts business for 20 years family owned
their goal is to make auto parts
available and affordable to keep you
safe on the road they not only have the
auto parts you need but they'll give you
a selection of trusted name brands to
choose from you can pick breaks that
match how you use your vehicle uh for
towing racing or just community work
whatever it is they've got it for you
the rockotter.com catalog is remarkably
easy to navigate quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
choose the brands and specifications and
prices you prefer the prices make it
affordable for customers to keep their
cars safe on the road there's an amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need go to
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now get brakes shocks carpets wipers
headlights mirrors mufflers lug nuts or
any other part you need at rockauto.com
as always be sure to write walsh in
their how did you hear about us box so
they know that i sent you
well i believe in giving credit where
it's due
even on the rare once in a century
occasion when it's due to the mainstream
media
and some are saying that that this is
just such an occasion some are saying
that this that this right now is the
time when we should give some credit to
the mainstream media yesterday cnn
featured a segment offering an update on
the byu
racism hoax now most media outlets uh
covered it you know back when when they
could pretend that there was actually a
racist white kid in the stands of a
volleyball game shouting the n-word and
they were covering it then but now that
that story has been revealed to be the
hoax it was always certain to be
they just have moved on and that's what
they always do
or usually do in these cases they report
the hoax and then when it turns out to
be a hoax and it's revealed as a hoax
and there's nothing that they can do to
pretend otherwise they move on and don't
talk about it anymore
cnn to their credit
did not
though in watching this segment which
we'll play a piece of it here for you
i'm not sure that they're due all of the
credit that people want to give to them
it's it's a step it's a little baby step
in the right direction it's a it's a
small step towards journalistic
integrity
but certainly not maybe the giant leap
that some would would hope that it would
be but let's listen
healthy skepticism is always a virtue
but this doesn't read like a cover-up
instead it feels like there was a rush
to judgment because of a
well-intentioned impulse to believe the
duke player's accusations
now we need to note that the
investigation does not call rachel
richardson a liar or a fabricator it
leaves open the possibility that she
sincerely believed that she heard
repeated racial heckling and that some
sort of misunderstanding occurred
for its part duke issued a statement
saying it was standing by its players
but notably the richardson family has
not yet responded to cnn's request for
comment
look systemic racism is real and
corrosive to the soul of our country but
facts always have to come first listen
to espn host stephen a smith who covered
the controversy extensively
racism
prejudice still exists in this country
we all know it we know how prevalent it
is and we know that it's something that
completely needs to be eradicated having
said that
we're not doing ourselves any favors
if
we bring it up and broach it
when it doesn't exist
and that's the key that we need to focus
on
that's right
and that's why it was surprising to hear
the head coach of the south carolina
women's basketball team don staley say
that she was still okay with canceling
her team's games against byu regardless
of the results of the investigation
staley says that she's standing by her
decision because of her own personal
research and commitment to the
well-being of her team but when
investigations turn up a very different
fact pattern it's incumbent upon
everyone to acknowledge it and adjust
you gotta love that the coach
south carolina coach says we're not
going to byu because there's a bunch of
rape because of this racist incident
and then you circle back and say well
you know the racism it never happened
the racist incident we're still
boycotting
well why but it didn't happen
because that's we feel like it did
now a couple of things here uh to begin
with
first of all is that cnn is covering for
stephen a smith here they're making it
sound like smith actually acknowledged
that he was wrong about this situation
and held himself accountable because
remember
as always with these race hoaxes
especially if they are in the realm of
sports espn is out in front leading the
pitchfork mob and in front of of all of
them is stephen a smith who's like you
know he's he is now the the ben crump or
the al sharpton of the sports analyst
world and i'm not sure if he's always
been that way but that's how he is now
that's that's the ground that he has
decided to stake out for himself
when you when you watch the whole clip
though we'll go go to espn the actual
the actual clip
and here are the 45 seconds that precede
the clip that cnn played and you listen
to this and tell me if this sounds like
any sort of maya culpa or an even is
this even an acknowledgement that he was
wrong listen to what he says
well first of all um
you can take it one of two ways you can
either believe
byu and take them at their word
or you can be a bit cynical and
skeptical about them drawing this
conclusion
questioning what level of veracity
should we attach to them
um pick your side
as it pertains to the duke player
she says she heard what she heard
she spoke about it with passion
uh we don't have any reason to believe
her duke is giving the impression that
they completely believe her
and in byu's statement they certainly
did not accuse her of lying they simply
said they found no evidence
okay so
he's not he's actually doubling down so
cnn you want to give them credit
for
sort of
acknowledging the reality of a situation
but at the same time they're they're
doing a favor to one of their
compatriots
in the media and making it sound like he
he actually doubles down he's what he's
saying
without without saying it totally
explicitly but he gets right up to the
edge of it he's he's he said i i still i
think that byu is lying because the way
he presents it is
well you know it's he said it's uh he
said she said right you could you could
believe byu and their claims or you
could believe this uh poor innocent
woman who heard what she heard and she
spoke with passion and if someone speaks
with passion they're clearly not lying
no that's not what it's it's not just a
oh one person says this and the other
says this and who knows
no it's actually
every single person at the game who was
interviewed
said they heard no such thing witnessed
no such thing
that all the security the police
everyone involved in the situation so it
is everybody
versus this one
girl who claimed who makes a claim
it's not it's not one versus one it's
not he should he said it's all of them
said everyone
versus this one person
and also keep in mind that the claim
this one person made was outrageous and
ridiculous to begin with
and it's also a claim that if it
happened there would be evidence of it
oh and it's also we're also not judging
this based on what people said there's
video you can go there's
uh
cell phone video security camera
you know they were filming
the school was filming the game
all of the video and audio nothing there
so it's all the video all the audio
everybody there versus what this one
person said and what stephen a smith
is implying is that well really we
should really you know still
no she spoke with passion after all
her passion outweighs all of the
evidence
i don't know if i can give credit to cnn
actually
and even if i could i don't
i'm not going to trip over myself
giving the media credit the news media
credit for doing what it's supposed to
do
if you report something and it turns out
that what you reported is not true or
there's a lot more to the story
you're supposed to report that also
so i've seen some people on the right
well you know give some uh
hats off to cnn at least they did this
what that's what you're supposed to do
you're the news media
the rare occasion that they sort of
accidentally do
part of what they're supposed to do
we're supposed to congratulate you
no
and also by the way both both uh stephen
a smith and cnn
are insisting
that the girl didn't lie well no one is
saying that she lied
uh
they might not be saying that but that's
obviously what happened she clearly lied
okay when when you claim something
occurred that did not occur
there are
two options
one is that you're lying
and the other is that you're
hallucinating
you know you're a lunatic hallucinating
or you're tripping on drugs or something
you know if it turns out they do a
toxicology maybe we could do a
toxicology on this girl if she was on
some sort of hallucinogenic drug or
something if she went there on lsd
and she was playing uh in a volleyball
match
that then maybe i would agree that she's
not necessarily a liar this was all part
of her of of her lsd trip
but assuming she was sober
um
then then she was lying
because either thing happened or didn't
and if you're sober and not crazy
there's no way that you could think
something like that happened if it
didn't happen
so yes she is a liar and that is
actually a very important
point in all of this
is that
uh
when a race hoax happens
and first we're told one story and then
it turns out that the true story is this
thing over here which is totally
divorced from the story we were told
it's not enough to just say oh yeah it
turns out that this is what really
happened that's not enough
i mean that's farther than most media
outlets will go because again they'll
just ignore it
but even to say yeah well turns out this
is what really happened that's not
enough you have to connect the dots and
it is actually important to say
that girl's a liar i'll say it
she is a liar she is a liar a con artist
a scammer she should there should be
criminal charges for something like this
because there's a real cost here this is
not just free speech you can make you
can this this is
defamatory she lied she is a scumbag
liar
and she was perfectly willing they they
took some random kid
and they
accused him of racism and she was
perfectly willing to let that kid live
with it
he's got to carry that for the rest of
his life
as the racist it was shouting the n-word
at a volleyball match and she was
willing for that to happen
he gets banned if he got expelled
whatever he she was fine with that
this is like sociopathic behavior
actually
and that is a really important part
to say that
it wasn't a mistake it wasn't a
misunderstanding it wasn't uh she feels
one way and they feel the other it's she
is a liar
and a terrible person and that's how she
should be labeled and seen
and she should carry that shame for the
rest of her life
all right
dr oz proving yet again why he's the uh
one republican in pennsylvania well i
mean he hasn't he's not in pennsylvania
actually he's in new jersey but he uh
he's the one republican who could
actually lose
to a man who at this point is like a
post lobotomy jack nicholson in one flew
over the cooker's nest so here's dr oz
he tweeted this
i'm proud to join this effort with
fellow republicans i believe that
same-sex couples should have the same
freedom to get married as straight
couples
and he's
reacting to referring to a washington
post article about prominent republicans
who are pushing other gop senators to
support this
this bill that would codify same-sex
marriage
now
no republican should support this bill
many have
we knew dr oz would i mean dr oz was on
board with chemically castrating
children he was ahead of the transiting
the kid bandwagon by several years he
was out 2011 2010
um talking about how wonderful it is
that we've got trans kids so no surprise
there
but no republicans should support it
even though many have many many more
probably will it should be self-evident
as to why but apparently it isn't
the bill seeks to codify
the redefinition redefinition of
marriage on a federal level
this will be the federal government
defining what marriage is and then
forcing that definition on to the states
now this is unnecessary to begin with
even from a leftist perspective because
or seemingly unnecessary from their
perspective because the supreme court
already imposed
this redefinition on the states and that
decision isn't going anywhere
despite what you may have heard that
decision is not going anywhere
now if it was just up to clarence thomas
maybe it would be but it's not
and the other justices even the
so-called conservative originalists
whatever you want to call them um i can
guarantee you that most of them would
not be on board
with
overturning the supreme court's
codification it's it's decree
that you know
uh
that the the old definition of marriage
is no longer legitimate they should be
on board with that but they're not they
should be on board with overturning it i
mean
um
but beyond that
is this really
conservative i mean to support the
federal government declaring what a
marriage is
and then telling the states to abide by
that
this is a conservative position
i mean ten years ago
it was
not a conservative position to support
gay marriage at all
and now the conservative position is to
not only support it but to support the
federal government
uh in stating it
across the country
and the worst thing is that
their
they're
i keep saying it's a redefinition of
marriage but that's not exactly the
right way
to put it because a redefinition
involves getting rid of an old
definition
and then coming up with a new one
but as we always talk about that's not
how redefinition works
on the left
the getting rid of the old definition
that that part they like so they'll come
along and say uh this word this term
that you've been using
and then in fact all of human society
has been using through in different
languages since the dawn of human
civilization uh it doesn't mean that
anymore that's not what it means
and then and then the
the immediate question and response is
well if that's not what it means what
does it mean now and they have no answer
to that
their only answer is how dare you you
ask that you big it
it just doesn't mean that that's it well
what does it mean uh it doesn't it it
doesn't mean that that's what we know
so they redefined marriage not by giving
it a new definition but by giving it no
definition at all now it just doesn't
really mean anything
they don't they don't know what it means
before it was um a fundamentally
procreative you know in principle
procreative union between a man and a
woman and it served as the foundation of
human society because males and females
are the only ones that can have babies
and start biological families and so the
marriage was the was the the the
platform the context within which those
families were started that's what
marriage was and then they said it's not
that anymore well then what is it
they don't have an answer
they have vague kind of bumper sticker
slogans about uh love is love anyone can
love anyone else well really anyone so
just any
any arrangement of people is now a
marriage well no don't be absurd that's
not what it is that's slippery slope
fallacy
well then what is it don't answer
they can't answer it
the other thing keep in mind about this
is that
this will absolutely be used to go after
the churches
this is another thing that shouldn't
have to be explained
that's actually why the left is doing it
so if you're wondering
given that there is actually no threat
to
gay marriage
so-called
there's no threat to it
so why are they doing it
it's because this is this is a move
against religious liberty it's a move
against the churches that's what it is
if they can codify on a federal level
with federal legislation
that
you know same-sex couples can get
married
that it's their right it's their human
right to get married
then they can turn around and say to the
churches you are denying these gay
couples their human rights
and obviously that that doesn't count as
religious liberty
right i mean churches have the freedom
to do what they want and to and to
exercise and profess their own religions
but they can't deny human rights to
somebody
and actually that part of the statement
is true that you don't have the right to
deny someone their human rights
even if your religion says that like if
your religion declares that you can go
and just
walk up someone and shoot him in the
head
well we would all agree that that's
no your religious liberty is not going
to cover that because you're taking away
their fundamental human right to live
the difference is that there is no human
right
to marry in whatever arrangement you
want that doesn't exist
but by codifying that concept on a
federal level that gives them the basis
it gives them the argument the weapon
that they need
uh the sledgehammer that they'll use to
beat the churches over the head
that's what this is and so any
republican or conservative doesn't
matter how you feel about gay marriage
as an issue
if you're supporting this then you are
supporting the move against the churches
and the move against religiously because
that's what is and and and the only
argument
on the other side
the only argument to um
try to debunk what i'm saying now is
that well
but the democrats have said they won't
do that though
yes this legislation would give them the
excuse it would give them a platform to
wage this war against churches but they
said they wouldn't
well if that argument if that's
compelling or convincing to you then
there's nothing else to even talk about
they said they wouldn't
i mean if if
if i had
a dime for every time democrats said
they wouldn't do some horrific thing and
then did it anyway i'd have
you know i have a few dollars by now at
least
um
i wanted to show you this this is just
an example of a slightly subtle slightly
slightly subtle bias and propaganda
in the media because sometimes it's
blatant sometimes a little bit more
subtle so this is the new york times
okay this is their
headline
or at least their caption when they
posted to twitter
oberlin college has agreed to pay
36.59 million dollars to a bakery that
said it was falsely accused of racism
after it caught a student shoplifting
oberlin college has agreed to pay
because a bakery said they were falsely
accused of racism
now this is no different than if the
headline said you know man
agrees
to spend life in prison without parole
after it is said that he killed someone
that's that's
what they're doing with this headline
no oberlin college first of all has not
agreed to pay
they've been ordered by the court to pay
because they defamed this bakery and
damaged their business and the lives of
the people running the bakery
tremendously
done in fact irreparable harm
so they've been ordered to pay but they
have fought tooth and nail to not pay
and they still have not paid
they have not agreed to pay
and it wasn't that the the bakery just
said it was falsely accused of racism
they were falsely accused of racism
the courts have multiple courts have
determined that
and even before before the courts
determined it we knew it was true
because the whole basis for the racism
claim that oberlin college and and
activists in the in the area came up
with is that
you know because this bakery
didn't allow themselves to be the
victims of shoplifting
um then they're racist
and in fact you know you could you could
go read into this case uh we've talked
about it before on the show but
the details of this case are just
really mind-boggling
when this first happened and these
students at oberlin college they went to
the bakery and they stole from it
and someone at the bakery tried to stop
them
because that's not your property you
have to pay for that there are laws here
or so they thought
the initial response from the college
was
um words to the effect of that
paraphrase but but not by much
that uh well can can you let can you let
them steal once like can every student
at least be allowed to steal one so if
if they're all if they only steal once
then don't don't go to the police about
that
the second time is different but
everyone should get one free you know
just one one free item they can just
walk in and take it
and because the bakery would not agree
to that arrangement would not agree to
be
to open themselves up to being victims
of theft
by college students
they were branded as racist
and this
wealthy highly funded well-funded
institution
launched into this years-long effort to
destroy this bakery simply because they
were trying to defend themselves from
thieves
that's what actually happened
so slightly different from the way the
new york times has presented it
this from the daily wire says warner
brothers altered the video game
multiverses last week to prevent the
scooby-doo character velma from calling
the police
i don't know if she also worked that
maybe she was working at a bakery too i
don't know for nearly 50 years the
scooby-doo franchise has shown the
mystery incorporated gang
solving crimes and
alerting police to the presence of
potential criminals but critics have
recently labeled velma a karen for doing
precisely what had seemed innocent
enough before flashing a wanted poster
and calling the cops on characters from
across the warner brothers discovery
catalog
warner brothers games announced last
week instead of calling the police velma
now solves the mystery and calls the
mystery
uh inc gang and the mystery machine to
take the bad guys away one petition that
drew a bare 34 signatures lambasted
warner brothers stating although
historically the scooby-doo gang has but
not always worked with the police to
catch the suspect within the cartoons
this cop car is not necessary in the
game nor does it add meaning to her
moveset whatever that means move set
is that a video game terminal for
decades and especially in recent times
black and indigenous people of color
around the world have suffered under
police brutality and this cop car is
ignoring the problem of police brutality
in this day and age
it was a petition with 34 signatures for
this video game
saying that uh black and indigenous
people are victims of police brutality
in in the real world and in video games
or at least they're traumatized when
they see references to the police in
video games and so for that reason she
shouldn't call the police i'm surprised
they didn't adjust the game so that
instead she calls calls a social worker
you know cause a therapist or something
to come
and then in the video game we could
that's what the video game would become
like velma
uh
finds the bad guy and then calls the
social worker calls a therapist and then
and then and then the video game you
actually get to see
the counseling session between the
criminal and the therapist you can you
can play it out with you know on the
game
until the therapist is just shot in the
head by the bad guy and that's the end
of the game
uh
34
signatures on a petition and
they decided to make the change
this just shows you again the the the
cultural power
the systemic power
that you have on the left
a few complaints and a change is made
this is we're talking about warner
brothers
it's a
[Music]
multi-multi-multi-billion dollar
corporation
and you would think that they've got all
the money in the world and all of the
the power and resources they need to
withstand pressure from a petition of 34
people who are claiming to be upset
because they saw something in a video
game
and they could withstand it but they
choose not to
because if you're on the left
you know your one vote culturally
speaking counts for like a million
you count for a million people
get 34 people together it's 34 million
people crying out
it has to say nothing in the fact that
why are there adults playing a
scooby-doo video game in the first place
i i read through some of these tweets
and there aren't many that were
complaining about this because but again
it doesn't need to be made it's like
just one person can complain and it'll
bring a corporation a billion dollar
corporation to its knees
um but the few people complaining seem
to be adults as far as i can tell
who not only are claimed to be
traumatized by a cop car interview again
but are playing a scooby-doo video game
to begin with
that's the real problem here
and by the way one thing i'll say about
adults playing video games this is kind
of a side note okay a sidebar here
because i know that i've i've i've been
hard on on grown up gamers in the past
and i always upset the gaming community
well it's not really a community just
because you all like playing video games
doesn't make any community but still
i always upset them when i talk about
this
and so i do want to acknowledge one
thing because this i think this is
important to acknowledge
that if you can do it in moderation
right play video games it is fine it's
just it's just recreation it's
relaxation whatever
now i think playing a scooby-doo video
game even in moderation is ridiculous
and embarrassing but it's not going to
hurt you if you're if in moderation like
every once in a while you like to sit
down and play a video game whatever
and it isn't all that different because
the comp when i talk about this the the
rejoinder the rebuttal
from the gamers is well you like you
watch football what's the difference
i think it is a little bit different
but but i get the point
you know um yeah it's a similar sort of
thing
now i watch basically one football game
a week all the way through and that's
only from september to january and i'll
watch other games on occasion you know
i'll check some scores here and there
that kind of thing but religiously i
will watch one game a week for about 17
weeks of the year
a few more weeks if the ravens don't
suck this year but it looks like they
probably do
there are people
who will watch football literally all
weekend long they watch college on
saturday they watch professional on
sunday and they watch all the games they
just sit there that's all they do there
are dads whose families lose them for
the entire football season like the the
weekends are gone all of football season
because both saturday and sunday are
completely dominated by the dad's desire
to just sit on his ass and watch
football
like 24 hours of football every weekend
and there are people whose fandom
consumes them they they take it very
very seriously way too seriously they
get into
i just saw another i think it was that
probably i'm assuming it was at a jets
game but maybe it wasn't um
you know violent altercation at a
football game people go to games and
they get into or they go to sports bars
and yeah there's drinking involved also
but they get into actual violent
altercations with other fans
about whose team is best and they start
they start trying to kill each other
over that's how seriously they take it
all of this is childish and sad
and it represents a recreational
activity
which has become a lifestyle
and that is where video games i think we
should say are a problem
that's why i don't like the phrase the
gamer community when you're referring to
it as a community now you've made it
into a lifestyle choice it's like your
life revolves around it
that that is the issue
and when we're adults
our lives should not revolve around
recreation
it should not revolve around our
favorite recreational activity our our
lives should not revolve around
entertainment
even our kids lives shouldn't revolve
around entertainment we should have we
should we should uh raise our kids to
have it richer more interesting more
vibrant
lives than that
that's the point okay let's get to the
comment section
do you know their name
frank s says the first documented slave
owner in american history was anthony
johnson a black man who was a former uh
slave himself slavery wasn't about black
versus white but rich versus poor
well um
if we're talking about slavery as an
institution historically you can't even
say rich versus poor obviously uh it it
it it uh could also be you know because
people were conquered and became slaves
so it was conquered versus conquerors it
was there were many different dynamics
now it's true that there are black slave
owners in the united states but largely
you know large largely for the most part
um
it was
white people owning black slaves that
that of course is true
the problem is when you try to say when
you're speaking about slavery in general
okay if we want to expand our horizons
to talk about the entire institution the
whole history of slavery which is what
we should be talking about that's a
conversation we should have
but it's such an ancient and ubiquitous
thing
that i mean what you can say about it is
exactly what i just said that it's
ancient and ubiquitous
that it's the ownership of humans it's
the debasement of the human person to
the level of property
that's what it is across all
cultures and and and uh throughout for
for thousands of years across the world
that's what it was
and it existed
and this is not again
when we talk about well there were slave
there's slavery other in other places in
the world that's not what about ism
it's just it's
an acknowledgement of
a really important historical reality
that people actually don't know
because
there is such a campaign to make sure
that we don't talk about it
all right
another comment says
the woman king should be canceled
because it has actors and actresses
portraying slaves and not actual slaves
such as lebron james and colin
kaepernick the multi-millionaires
enslaved by the nba and the nfl
very good point i hadn't thought about
that
um dominique says every time matt says
dahomey it's the funniest statement i've
ever heard yeah i almost made a joke
about that but fortunately the spg in
the comments took care of that for me i
knew i didn't have to make the joke
because you'd pick up on it
i don't know if i was mispronouncing
the the ancient african kingdom but i
mean it's spelled d-a-h-o-m-e why so i
think it's
pronounced to homie
so it's the kingdom of dahomey
you know dahomey down the way don't mess
with the homie
the homie don't play that that's these
are all things you could say
about the kingdom of the homie it's like
this historically accurate thing to say
and i'm not making a joke about it to be
clear i was going to say people in the
comments are making jokes i'm not making
that joke i'm just saying the homie
is what it's called uh
heather mccoy says if we're if we spg
are doing flannel friday then matt needs
to come up with his own flannel pattern
patent it and make it available with the
rest of the spg merch for now but almost
positive he could be a retailer to offer
them as well
also as a special sockware myself i was
outraged to hear that you saw you
subscribed to a sock company that would
not throw in a free laundry sock mesh
with your first order to ensure the safe
return of such an important item uh yeah
we we actually did have this very
conversation can we is it possible for
me to have my own flannel
my own line of flannels that isn't
that's actually like my ultimate dream
in life i think if i had that then my
career would be complete i could
actually retire that's what all has been
leading to actually it's all been
leading to
me having me being a fashion designer of
my own line of flannels i don't know if
that's possible how feasible it really
is
but i will i will pursue that
i will never give up on my dreams
nate says i don't think matt can say the
word the word portion
am i saying that word wrong portion
portion is that not the right way to say
it portion
now i'm saying the word too much and
it's lost all meaning when you say a
word too much so
you're banned from the show for that
well if you didn't hear we had a big
announcement this week candace owens is
back from maternity leave with a
vengeance her brand new show candace
owens launches uh well in fact it
launched yesterday on daily wire plus
and takes on the big topics of the day
uncovers lies and exposes the hypocrisy
in news and politics and you know it's
going to be done in typical canada's
style fearless and resolute this is
everything you love about candace only
now she's streaming five days a week
you'll not want to miss her explosive
first episode which premiered yesterday
trust me when i say this it's huge so
watch candace always the
daily wire plus or listen on apple
podcast spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
our cancellation today begins
brian stelter but does not end with him
we have already covered the tragic news
of the death of stelter's beloved cnn
show beloved by stelter himself at least
and that ought to that ought to have
been good enough i mean he liked doing
it
for many years it was good enough as
stelter pulled in a handsome paycheck
and hosted a show without any pressure
to actually generate you know an
audience
but then the gravy train came to a halt
and brian was understandably devastated
because
he loves gravy obviously and also he
loves his job at cnn perhaps even more
but that job is now gone
what will he do now that he's unemployed
will he apply for an assistant manager
job at best buy will he be uh
will he start making a living selling
his art his homemade arts and crafts
projects on etsy well he wind up on the
street homeless and jobless
where he could at least get more public
exposure than he ever did at cnn
no unfortunately
brian has suffered a fate far more
embarrassing and shameful than that he
just got a job at harvard the hill
reports quote brian stelter a former cnn
host and noted media pundit
is joining harvard kennedy school's
schorenstein center on media politics
and public policies delta will serve as
a media and democracy fellow and convene
a series of discussions about what the
center described as threats to democracy
and the range of potential responses
from the news media
quote these discussions with media
leaders policy makers politicians and
kennedy school students fellows and
faculty will help deepen public and
scholarly understanding about the
current state of the information
ecosystem and its impacts on democratic
governance the school said in an
announcement
now at first glance this seems to be an
interesting career path brian stelter is
a graduate of towson university in
maryland towson university is renowned
for being the sort of school where you
can graduate with honors even if you
were only sober for like three or four
cumulative days throughout your entire
college career not unlike most every
other college in america admittedly
though stelter to his credit was surely
sober far more often than that mostly
because
you know nobody invited him to parties i
assume
but the question is this how does a
towson graduate
who hosted a little scene weekend cnn
show
wind up working in the ivy league
and how did he land this job so quickly
after getting canned
the answer is that stelter
although a mediocre talentless dishonest
hack
is part of a system he's part of an
apparatus
and now that he's in it he never has to
leave
he can just be cycled through from one
institution to the next failing at one
job and then the other and always ending
up with another job even more
prestigious than the one before
it's likely that you know next he'll
have some sort of bureaucratic post and
then he'll end up back in the media
again and then maybe find he'll find
himself sitting on a corporate board
somewhere
for people like stelter the system is
like a lazy river at a water park you
know all you need to do is just sit on
an inner tube and float around in
circles from one stop to the next it's
as easy as that
now stelter is of course not the only
piece of human driftwood floating on
this very fortunate tide it works this
way for all of them jen pasaki left her
job at the white house immediately
secured her next gig at nbc actually she
secured the gig
even before leaving her job at the white
house karen jean pair on the other hand
went from nbc to the white house this is
how it works academia media government
always trading players between each
other swapping one for the other
corporate america is also part of this
club
all of these institutions are staffed
and run by the same people that's all
that's why they all work in tandem with
each other it's why they're always on
the same page it's why they are in
effect
one organization they're different limbs
of the same body
now you sometimes hear these ruling
institutions referred to as
the cathedral the idea i think is that
the media academia government corporate
america they not only rule over the
country and govern our lives but they
also act as the intellectual core of
society just as the church once did in
earlier times they decide what sort of
ideas we must accept and which we must
reject they tell us what is true and
what is not um and again they're always
on the same page
they never disagree with each other
never
today they have decided that men can get
pregnant and that white people are
inherently evil and that you know obese
obesity is beautiful and dozens of other
absurd propositions there is no
disagreement between any of these
institutions on any of these subjects or
any other subject they present a united
front taking even the most insane sorts
of ideas and instantly normalizing them
that's the effect here
because they're all on the same page and
they're all effectively one institution
they can take any idea no matter how
ridiculous and instantly just like that
it is normal
because of the fact that through these
institutions they're able to
uh normalize anything
now i think the cathedral is an apt
label to describe this system i also
think the system could be called simply
the system others you know call them the
ruling class or the elite or the
oligarchy
all of those terms apply
personally i do wonder whether it
deserves a slightly more i don't know
scatological description
perhaps we could refer to the media
academia government corporations and big
tech as the as the uh kind of our
country's giant human centipede
and if that's too grotesque and maybe it
is then here's another idea um the
octopus
you know an octopus has one large brain
but each of its eight tentacles have
their own kind of mini brains this
allows the tentacles to operate
independently of each other and yet
always in service to the whole
so the arms have minds of their own sort
of but also not really because even if
all the tentacles don't require the
conscious direction of the large brain
in order to operate they're all part of
the same octopus they work they work
apart but
together this is the mystery of the
octopus in the sea and of our ruling
institutions they appear to operate as
independent entities and yet they are
all tentacles of the same slimy hideous
sea monster working towards the same end
now we hear quite a lot from the media
and politicians about the need to defend
our democracy in fact that's what brian
stelter's going to be talking about
that's what he's done he's going to be
teaching classes and holding seminars
about this over at harvard
and yet
they all work to maintain this system
this octopus whose very existence makes
democracy essentially irrelevant
because in a real functioning democracy
these institutions would have
antagonistic or at least indifferent
relationships towards each other the
media
okay if we really had a democracy that
functions
the media would act as a watchdog
holding the government accountable
academia would stand apart from these
other two and business would focus on
business
instead they all have the same
ideological agenda they even hire from
the same pool of candidates
this means that if the voters do make a
decision that the other tentacles
disapprove of
they'll just turn against the intruder
like white blood cells attacking a virus
and undermine the voter selection until
a system approved person can be
installed in his place this of course is
exactly what happened with donald trump
now
brian stelter is a small player in all
of this but he's also emblematic
his show on cnn was ostensibly a show
about media criticism but all he did was
defend the media
and then when biden was in office he
defended the government too
that's why he will remain in the system
forever taken care of
because they take care of their own
perpetually
failing upwards
and who was he defending these
institutions against well you and me
because we're the peasants the rabble
the subjects and it's our job to listen
and accept whatever we're told
and behave as we are instructed
if we fail in that regard then we are
the enemy
and and all of the tentacles will agree
on that point too
that's why this thing whatever you want
to call it the octopus the cathedral the
human centipede the incestuous orgy of
mediocrity whatever it is
is today canceled and that'll leave it
there for us for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you over there and
become a daily wire member if you
haven't yet so that you can join us for
uh the last part of the show every day
otherwise talk to you tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you